[Music]
so the title of this talk is overstated
journey how we get from like a few
terabytes of data 200 plus petabytes of
data and how we lower down the data
latency from one or two days down to
mean minute level my name is reza shift
FR i joined over in 2014 i was one of
the founding engineer on the data plat
the data platform to maneuver i'm
currently managing the Hadoop platform
team at uber and this will be basically
our past few years journey in terms of
scaling the data at uber and lowering
the latency in terms of the agenda so
we're gonna have a quick intro in terms
of like how data is used at uber then
I'll start with okay where we started
what are different iterations that we
went through to scale the business and
then where we're standing right now and
then I'll try to focus mostly on what's
coming up next and I summarize the main
learnings from the hotel from our
experience at the end so a quick intro
in terms of uber so I hope most of you
are familiar with over so our ubers
mission is to provide transportation as
reliable as running water anywhere
everywhere and to everyone that you
reach to do this we need to be
physically accessible to most of the
people that's why the business has to
scale to be in all the cities that
people live in currently we are in 600
plus cities 75 plus countries and we're
still growing so now looking at the
business from data point of view so it's
obviously a data driven company almost
all decisions made at the company are
based on some data points studying the
trends of data and how people react to
like decisions made in the past so we
based on that we can categorize the
users of our data at the company into
three main categories first is the city
ops these are the guys the folks that
run cities so every city is managed by
individuals who
our family are with the local
environment so we are talking about
thousands of City ups who basically
relies on worse data to make decisions
for their city and the other hand we
have the second category of later users
who are data scientists and data
analysts
these are the folks who study that they
try to figure out explore the data and
find the use cases a good example is
okay you want to see how many cars you
need on the road on the New Year's Eve
so this is a forecasting problem so you
need to look at the data you need to
look at the trends from the past few
years and with some weird algorithm
you're going to be able to make that
decision so these are the folks who
explore the data we are talking about
several hundreds of them currently
looking at the data and then we have the
engineering teams these are the
engineering teams that provide services
and products to the rest of the company
to basically help the business grow and
these guys are the guys who use the data
to basically serve their own service to
provide some additional level of of
products on top of that a good example
is fraud detection liking a right as
safer and safe or basically finding any
fraud going on with the trip so these
are the platforms and services built on
top of our data so if you're again
talking it was several hundreds of these
folks now before getting into basically
where we started our journey a quick
overview like in terms of where we were
before 2014 we were so small that
basically all the data was fitting in a
few traditional DB's so services were
right into I think at that time post PSO
my stick hold and basically anyone who
leads the data had to go and get the
connect with those DVDs and access to
the data so the data size was very small
it was ordered of a hundred gigabytes or
two terabytes and the latency was very
low because you had to go and directly
access a traditional DB but obviously
you didn't have all the data in one
place you have to go to multiple TVs to
excite your data so this is way way in
the past then we start the big data
error at uber so this started in 2014
and the business starts to grow at the
same time the data stores to grow too so
we call this like the first generation
so based on the experience that
most of the guys on the team had been at
the different companies so we started
putting together pieces the fundamental
pieces to make the business scale and
have all the data in one place this
starts like with a basically a bit of
overall view of the data platform at
that time which if you look at it from
the left hand side so we start adding
Kafka Kafka 7 was a trend at the time so
a lot of us have used it in the past
it's very easy for users to use so we
introduced that to the service there was
no Hadoop or any concept like that there
so we have to pipe it to announce on AWS
3 restore the data then our business was
growing so the data were not fitting
into one traditional database anymore so
our storage team came of it ok what's
the easiest solution let's chart the
data so they build a key value on top
out like this chart that my stick was so
that helps at least the business to grow
and the troops to be served at the same
time we had still smaller data sets that
fit in one database so this is on the
left you can see they're basically the
main data sources we had at the time so
we want it all they had to be one place
we had folks who had experience with
data warehousing so they suggested
basically going with some data
warehousing tools like Vertica so we
added birth together we obviously build
a bunch of pipelines in Java a bunch of
scripts to get the data some
transformations some massaging and
putting it into Vertica so we built a
Python the data was pointing and
basically we stood the fear for the
first time we started seeing all the
data in one place so this was very
encouraging to the city herbs and the
users because now they had single view
on the whole data there were one place
you can go there where to go has perfect
support for sequel so you can even city
offs who doesn't know how to interact
with DBS they can't code there would be
put a portal on top of that so they can
go to a UI and basically issue sequel
statement if that was a at the time
revolutionary thing for the wait cities
were managed at at the same time since
all the data was in one place data
scientists started playing with the data
there are applications being made on top
of these data so more and more users
started lying at this data and this is
what happened between 2014 to 2015 again
to give you a sense of the size and they
can see we are talking about server also
this lets us grow
a few terabytes to tens of terabytes and
the latency was like basically one or
two days for a new data to show up and
I'll dig into why that was the case so
the main highlight from the first
generation of the PI platform that we
built was it lets us go to tens of
terabytes of data it provides us with a
global world view of all the data in one
place
vertical had great support for sequels
so a lot of CT ops we didn't have
computer background were able to access
the data so more and more number of
users were able to access the data most
importantly a lot of people as hundreds
of people were able to run queries at
the same time you can't do that on a
traditional database you'd be thought
busy affecting the life track again
they're right throughput so here you be
had another view of it so multi people
could run query at the same time so a
lot of applications specifically ad-hoc
queries could be executed on top of the
data but that was a good win at a time
and the problem is okay it was us first
try so there are a lot of drawbacks with
that so I summarize a few of the
limitations with that approach first one
data reliability so there was no notion
of schema at the time so schema was more
word-of-mouth you have to go and talk to
people to know okay what the scheme of
data is at the source everything was
basically based on JSON in online world
so this JSON needs to be converted into
some vertical tables you have to put
structure on top of that and you don't
know have any contract so you have to
put all those logic into ETL pointer so
which means the ETL jobs or scripts that
you had were very fragile so any change
of format or any any any change would
break them all the time so that was a
big issue for data reliability we have
scalability obviously our data the
business was going very fast the data
was also growing very fast a lot of new
applications were building on top of
this data that themselves generates a
new sets of data so the data was really
growing very exponentially the problem
was vertical we were using vertical in
the wrong way we were basically using it
as a data leak rather than addictive
warehousing - so we were dumping all the
raw data into vertical data modeling was
happening on top of vertical and the
result was stored in so that was
basically the main drawback with scaling
the whole thing and there there were a
lot of parts in our infrastructure at
the time that were not horizontally
scalable so I talked about
after seven so it's not horizontally
scalable Deborah Kafka 8 coming out at
those time but we didn't have the
infrastructure at that one so that's the
second one and the third limitation with
first generation was basically the
ingestion was very fragile so we were
ingesting the same data source multiple
times in our data warehouse with
different transformation logic that
basically creates a lot of pressure on
the source data store that you bring in
data in at the same time you re
ingesting the same data over and over
without knowing what's going on the jobs
were specifically depending on the
source data and the schema that you had
agreed with someone so it could have
break at any time and then backfilling
was a really painful thing at the time
because again you didn't even know what
you're picking the same day time
so all these resulted in basically are
moving to our next generation of data
platform this is the time that we
introduced had you and this is the time
frame of 2015-2016 so very high level
this is how we end up implementing so
starting from the very left we have we
still had the shorted databases we
upgraded obviously to Kafka 8 that lets
us to be horizontally scalable we made a
decision at this time that for our
ingestion platform we don't want to have
transformation as part of the ingestion
which means we don't want to reinvest
the same data over and over so our basic
assumption at that point was you ingest
once into head you then people can play
around with the data in Hadoop and do
whatever whatever transformation they
want in Hadoop the good thing is you
have a gate there you don't let garbage
gets in you don't have you don't let go
top to do the case of data yet see and
it also helps us by having a gateway
that it allowed us to enforce schema so
we were ingesting a very interesting
data putting schema on top of that and
putting it into Hadoop
so any data with bad schema or any data
that's garbage and you can easily use it
it didn't even get into Hadoop so that
was a big win and I'll talk about how
that helps us to scale later and then we
are talking about a white schemas that
we had at the time so we had a table
like data again these were Jason's and
very evolved over time so we're talking
it was several hundred thousand columns
which several the level of nesting so we
need a columnar file format to store
had to first say with the spacing the
storage cost at the same time make the
queries which usually touch a few fields
or a few columns be more more per format
so we end up picking part K at the time
mostly because of integration with spark
so that's a bit you bet at that time
that Parker and spark is going to be our
fundamentals part of the data platform
then we moved all the ETL parts all the
transformation happens in within hadoo
so the good thing is okay any failure
stop you can catch up pretty fast
because you have stuff in a scalable
medium and then we did all the modeling
the flattened the data model the tables
and then only the output the recent
dates that you care about birth transfer
to vertical which means we started to
get closer and closer to really using
vertical in the right way which is as a
data warehousing - at the same time we
added query engines on top of our Hadoop
data we added hive we had this
introduced spark we added presto and
notebooks so dates attracted a lot of
users within the company from data
scientist to application developers to
city off to start running queries on top
of Hadoop rather than basically all
going to the warehouse so the main gains
from our second generation all data was
landing in Hadoop data leaks so data
format was moved to a columnar format
that helps with storage and query time
time all the ETL was happening in Hadoop
and only a subset of data that was
business critical and really needed in
in our data warehousing was transformed
there presto was a basically one of the
main attraction for people to start an
inquiry on top of Hadoop it lets you run
queries like interactive queries which
is like a big win for people who wanna
quickly get some results rather than
using traditional hype that is very
scalable but it takes from usually long
time to get the results back we also
added notebooks on top of our data in
Hadoop which helps like data scientists
also migrated over to us and so the big
wins basically Hadoop became the source
of truth for all the data we had all the
analytical data in one place all the
business critical products start using
relying on her do it this is actually
the time that the real power of data was
basically unlocked because you can you
had order later in one place you could
have access it you could up try play
with it run multiple queries and get it
is also and then most importantly making
all parts of our in platform
horizontally scalable
it lets us basically starting to
stabilize the infrastructure which
basically lets us get out of the
firefighting mode and start thinking
okay what do we need to invest for long
term so to give you a sense of like the
scale you were running at the time so it
is like from early 2016 we we were able
to get a few tens of petabytes of data
in Hadoop we had around 10 terabytes of
data per new data coming in per day or
Hadoop cluster was having like a few
tens of thousands of my course and we
were running over a few hundred
thousands of bad jobs per day but again
the business was going over it was being
added a lot of new stuff was coming out
so the data was still growing faster
than we could handle
we decided at the beginning that it's
best to have our own prime data centers
so we were using obviously clouds
products but our main a platform was
basically established on top of our own
datacenter so again mapping these
second-generation that's why I called
the Hadoop fort with the one we had
previously before that so first the
issue with the schema was so we didn't
let the data with bad skin what to get
in and we build services around that you
build a schema service and libraries for
all the peoples to integrate with the
schema from the beginning before
producing the data if you don't
integrate with the producer size of if
you don't have the producers integrate
with the schema then you are dealing
with bad data so you either have to drop
it or you have to basically go the hard
way and try to fix it which is not
scalable so we wanted bad data to be
stopped at the beginning that's why we
invested in building those services that
prevents bad data from getting into the
pipeline in the first place we also saw
their scalability issue relatively by
making all the parts of the platform
horizontally scalable we added hadoo we
added we upgraded to Kafka 8 but those
stuff helps to be scalable it
lability at the time we fixed the issue
with fragile ingestion we introduced the
notion of titled Lake and we decided to
let data to flow in once raw data as is
ingest at once and then anything
everything else happens to be unhappy on
top of that and we moved the data
modeling out of particle into Hadoop so
one thing I skipped briefly is okay we
did all this stuff the infrastructure
becomes relatively stable we were able
to horizontally state but the latency
was not touched the latency of the data
was still 24 hours and the reason is if
the nature of our data so that requires
digging a little bit deeper into what
the data we are dealing with I talked
about are basically key data sets to be
stored in charted databases I think
about the example of trips so we have a
charted device that you can store cheap
Santos so that's scalable awesome the
problem is now you want to get a copy of
that data into Hadoop very fast so two
options like you go and make a snapshot
or fetches from the source over and over
but that puts a lot of pressure on your
databases and you're competing with
basically the writers you don't want to
affect the trips that are happening
right now so you need to basically
shield yourself from affecting the chips
that are happening so to do that we
decided to move with the change locks so
we started basically tailing the changed
over these TVs and getting it to handle
the problem is we are our data by nature
has a lot of updates which means you can
basically and then think about the
Hadoop side we were storing the data in
Parque columnar five formats so now
you're getting updates you have columnar
file formats so there's no way you can
go and update them easily so what we did
we needed needed a data store some
technology that lets us basically
compact this data and basically merge
the new values with the old values and
bring a new snapshot and we decided at
the time to go with HBase that was the
one we had experience with and it was
really performant for a good case so we
get this change dot we keep keep merging
them with the previous data in each
space every few hours we went and
gimmick a new snapshot of data converted
to Parker bring it into Hadoop and then
users would see the new data obviously
this is not the best
sufficient way of bringing you data into
Hadoop again we started in January 2016
at that time with 500 executors our jobs
was taking six hours so we could have
refreshed our data every four times per
day so RS today was basically six hours
but the data was growing really
exponential so by August of the same
year our jobs were running 10 hours and
we actually doubled the number of
executors so we're having support jobs
with thousand executives running for 10
hours to bring the data in it's exciting
to have sparse jobs with thousand
executors but this was definitely not
the right use of our of our compute
resources
same thing with ETL parts so you get all
these raw data into Hadoop port there
was no easy way for them to know ok what
has changed so every time they want to
move up the basic update one of the
module tables this can be the D more
fact tables they had to reach create
that tables which means they are
creating the data over and over and
that's why their run time was between 8
to 10 hours - so the whole thing
end-to-end was still having an agency of
24 hours so that's the reason for them
so - to basically summarize the
limitations that we faced with
generation 2 so we had scalability issue
B again we had had you but we started
saying HDFS limitations so small files
were everywhere we have basically we
were starting to see other key the
performance of name was are going down
at at the same time the daintier the
ingestion platform that we had been very
base or specific so it was not easy to
add new sources or to basically operate
it we also have a very high latency of
24 hours again at still we are bounded
by ok we are getting updates and and
late arriving data how are we gonna
absorb it within head-to-head vs. them
at the same time ETL and the modeling
part becomes start to become the
bottleneck again the reason is ok they
were still doing a snapshot based
modeling and that was obviously not
scalable so this leads to generation 3
and this is the platform that we
currently running at uber so to give you
a sense of in terms of like the cluster
size data size these numbers are from
early 2017
so our HDFS was running about 100
petabytes we have several hundred
thousand because in our Hadoop clusters
we had a few hundred thousands of press
turquoise birthday a few thousands of
spark jobs and if you tens of thousands
of hype courts but again this data was
still growing faster than you could
watch oh so this time the motivation was
okay now we have everything hadoo hadoo
is becoming very popular because of the
interactive car engines that they put on
top of that and we are out of the
firefighting mode so let's start looking
into what we really need and think about
an infrastructure that helps us scale in
long term so going over there the
limitations that I just mentioned with a
previous architecture first HDFS
scalability this was a tough one to fix
but it's relatively straightforward
because it has been done at other places
other companies in the past they share
their experience so it's relatively
straightforward to follow so basically
we all know name knows is always going
to be the bottlenecks small files is
kind of in with the killer so you can go
with like name what Federation's adding
the ufs and by doing some stuff basic
it's splitting your Hadoop space into
multiple smaller space you can scale
your data in our case we did a bunch of
stuff and then remove our HBase cluster
to a separate HDFS cluster we moved all
your nap logs to a separate HDFS cluster
so this stuff lets us scale or HDFS
closer to 100 petabytes and again I'm
skipping the details here to get to the
data part of it
but we have recently published an
engineering block worse than that if you
guys want to know the details I'd refer
you to watch to that so the second
problem was okay the second and third
problem we want faster data in Hadoop
and we have updates as well as deletes
and we have Parque so first question was
like it can be get it off Parque no
because we have a lot of columns we have
a lot of deep levels of nesting so we
have five six levels of nested data so
we can't find anything we can over
replace Park it was something similar
but we're gonna end up with column or
file format which prevents us from doing
it updates so if we need to solve that
problems of updates at the same time for
the eto the maddening part they want to
be faster enough which means they had to
move out of the snapshot mode which
means they shouldn't regenerate the same
data over and over
so these are the main problems that we
wanted to show and a little bit more
details in terms of basically why we do
have updates to think about our so this
should give you a good sense of why
update was a natural part of our data so
think about like the trips we are
storing them in charted databases
awesome we're getting the incremental
changes out every few minutes awesome
now in Hadoop to blanket more accessible
more easier to access data you partition
the data the partitioned data are based
on when the tree was first created and
we do that at date level so if you look
at Hadoop data for example this like we
have one partition in Hadoop per day for
chips that happens on that day now let's
think about like this case okay this is
all your data in Hadoop on the right
hand side it starts from 2010 and we
have till 2018 today so now let's say
that we have like one new batch of data
coming if I run a batch of data right
now obviously most of it is going to be
new tips that happens today or a few of
the emperor from yesterday that was
basically blocked somewhere in the
pipeline so these are the green boxes
that you can see here so most of these
greens that are insert new data being
arrived goes to recent partitions at the
same time we get a bunch of updates on
our data - in these updates can be for
the past few days someone had an issue
with the cheap prices that has changed
or it can be okay you rate a driver next
time we take a ride if you're taking a
ride not maybe daily basis you take a
ride after a week or two so you're
basically rating a trip from two weeks
ago so again this by the nature of the
data of the get we have a long tail up
update going pass from few days to a few
months and these are the orange ones
that you can see so we get an updates
the rate of updates for trips has
temporal locality so it goes down as you
can move backwards in time and and
obviously so we need to find a way to
absorb this stuff so what did we do we
we introduced a new abstraction storage
abstraction layer on top of our data
it's basically a spark library called
hoodie it stands for Hadoop observes an
incremental pool what it does it
basically lets you update and delete
your previous data on top of Park a on
top of Hadoop
so that's the abstraction layer it
creeps you at the same time for the
users point of view it lets you pull
only the changes out but think about the
route tables okay so there's two
problems with that I get an hour update
on it trips from let's say three months
ago I need to find a way to be able to
update that trips in that parking lot
that's one problem the second problem is
the person who is reading this data or
the ETL job who's using this data this
is like three months old updates so
there's two ways for them to do basic in
catch that update one is they keep
scanning the whole table to find those
update based on some timestamp or some
notion of time or a bit which is very
inefficient or we give them a basic
primitive that they can get the updates
regardless of when that happens and that
is what we do provides it lets you pull
the changes that include obviously the
new data that inserted as well as any
updates that happened in the past so
these are two primitives that woody
provides absurd on top of the existing
Parker data as well as the incremental
data and by the way who is an open
source project so if you're interested
feel free to check it out so all these
were captured in our new generation tree
of the data pipeline so to walk you
through that so again the or source of
data were main trips data were still
stored in short at the beach was were
scalable we had good experience with
those so we keep them around we were
getting all the change logs out they
exchanged over obviously going through
Kafka and then we have an ingestion jobs
that gets discharged a lot and now the
good thing is we have woody so we can go
and update in seven as we insert or
delete the data in in Hadoop we talked a
sticky needing to create a new snapshot
this was a very big revolutionary thing
for us first it lets us to lower our
data less nnessee from 24 hours to 30
less than 30 minutes because now you
didn't bring need to bring all the data
in again over and over you were able to
go and update a previous data
think about it our tips at that time was
about a hundred terabytes of data so and
then amount of new data you get per day
is a few tens or hundreds ego bytes so
400 gigabytes of new data you
ingesting 100 terabytes of data over and
over this helps us to be efficient and
lower our data latency on the other hand
for the models part that model tables
you now had a primitive that lets you
pull only the changes out so you don't
need to regenerate your model tables or
wrists and the entire source table to
see the changes you can specifically ask
for changes on that table and only use
that in your modelling basically logic
to update your output tables so this
allows us to lower our data latency from
24 hours to 30 minutes for raw data and
for one hour on a visit for the model
tables and to give you a sense of the
data size we're talking about this is
like around 100 petabytes of data and so
okay so hoody provides you a new way of
processing your data which we call it
incremental processing if you think
about traditional lambda architecture
you have a streaming site you have a
batch side there is relatively known
distinction between these two a
streaming side is very fast but it's
less accurate you may not know what to
do with the updates first the real
traditional lambda is only based on they
append only data but again if you have a
streaming site you get an update or an
late arriving data you have to decide
what you deal with that most aware time
we just skip that and wait for the batch
site which has higher accuracy it's
basically a relatively complete no room
for basically missing any data and you
wait for that to basically back through
the data and update your ultimate
results but this is like basically there
was two solution you go with streaming
or bad or a combination of both what we
introduced here is incremental
processing this which means think about
it you are having mini batches and not
mini batches you're having a mini
batches with only the changed data so
you basically getting all the powers
from the batch side so you have your
running batch shop so you can do full
choice you can in streaming you have
strict limitation in terms of how you do
joints here you have the full power of
Hadoop so you can do basically anything
that a batch of can't you at the other
hand your data source you're getting the
exact changes at the source so
you you're not dealing with streaming
site that you get some updates and you
don't know what to do with you get all
the changes and you can decide how to
absorb it so this is a new intermediate
level of processing of our upstream data
and we basically align the timeline as
you can see on the bottom of this page
so based on the latency that the user
expect so if you are expecting a few
seconds of latency your only solution is
to go with a database if you are talking
about a few minutes of basically query
latency you can go with a stream
processing obviously if you're talking
about a few hours of data latency you
can go with batch processing anything
between 5 to 10 minutes to 1 hour that's
where the incremental processing shines
and Huda provides that capability to
have to basically to process the data
based on that ok so I need to skip a few
slides so if you other things that we
did that this part was first we
standardized our hive data model for raw
data so we are getting a change out from
upstream so we provided 2 standard views
on the data one is a merged snapshot
view which means ok what is the most of
all the values I've listed for for a
specific row again think about our data
set it has a lot of updates so we want
the users to be able to get a snapshot
of all the values at the same time users
want to see the history of changes and
that's what we introduced the new sets
of data model the data tables that
called change lock history that shows
you ok what are all these change doc
data behind the scene so all these put
together allowed us to basically have a
very generic ingestion platform to get
all the data in schema schema was baked
from the beginning we have hoodie and
let's update the data at the same time
this basically allowed us to open this
data as a good quality data for the
people to take out of Hadoop
so we had both the ingestion and
dispersal side implemented on top of
this stuff ok so now this moving fast
forward to what we are dealing with
right now
so they managed the the main efforts
that we're working right now is first
data quality so basically that is an
ongoing thing we had schema schema at
the time was doing
type checking it was a structural check
on your data we want to go beyond that
we don't want to say okay this is an
integer or not you want to say is this
an integer between the range of 0 to 20
or not so we're moving from basic type
checking to semantic checking to
checking okay defining our own specific
data types and be able to limit the
ranges and the types between that
semantics that's what I'm going for that
we're doing again we brought down the
latency of a data down to 30 minutes but
our business by nature is real-time
people wants it up faster and faster so
we have to move beyond that so we are
working on bringing the latency down to
five to ten minutes and the second thing
is efficiency okay when your data grows
you can scale your services but you have
to keep an eye on the cost so it's super
easy to miss that part and in particular
like a huge bill so efficiency at our
scale is becoming a big thing so we are
doubling down on where we can improve
this stuff both technology device and as
well as the devices that we have around
and then a lot of these stuff are
dealing with 2d so if you have different
stuff going on to take it to the next
level and I think I need to skip these
details and I basically skip a bunch of
details but this slide I think it's
going to be stretched so have a look I
have office hours afterwards if you want
to talk to me so alright I'll basically
jump into the lessons we learned out of
this first is investigate your data and
your use cases and find the required
primitives based on your use case again
think about this we introduced at hoody
and the support will update and delete
basically two and a half years ago
nowadays a lot of you must you are
dealing with gdpr requirements which
means you have to go and delete or
update it at the old data right for us
that's the sole problem because our
primitives was the one that we needed so
for us updating gdpr requirements is
relatively straightforward the other
thing is data quality is going to be
always ongoing so start basically
tracking and pushing for that from the
beginning schema is a big part of that
if you don't have schema enforce
do that as soon as possible this is the
main distinction between have a huge
data Lake full of garbage or having a
data lag that basically powers the rest
of the business
so data quality very important stuff the
second thing is standardized everything
do not make exception any exception you
make at scale can come back at you at
you and it Slater's extremely hard to
fix those stuff so do the right thing
you have to say no at some point but go
with that it pays back over time then
retention policy okay if you provide no
retention or basically standard
retention for everything people are used
to that later changing that behavior
behavior is extremely hard if you want
to go and delete users data beyond a
certain time people will start screaming
so you have to have a policy even if you
don't enforce it have that policy
written as soon as possible let people
know that okay these data they should is
it comes at a cost if they want to store
data forever it's over time it's going
to add to the cost
make sure you track order your metadata
any anything any date the metadata
around data itself is super valuable
later when you want to know okay who is
generating this data who are accessing
this data what's the data lineage
Vitesse with different data sets track
all the metadata as soon as possible
invest in a good quality in a scalable
data pipeline data monitoring so data
monitoring it's extremely important
because regardless of what you use and
how good you decide that there's going
to be always corner cases that you're
gonna miss data or there's going to be
people think the data is missed so
invest in a good data monitoring it
helps you basically catch a lot of
issues before the user start campaigning
about those and try to minimize your
dependency on user defined values user
defined values it's gonna always break
its gonna break the job our tables for
the rest of the company try to replace
those by system you find values as soon
as you can and so basically if you are
interested to be part of the next gen of
uber we are obviously hiring come talk
to me afterwards I have an office hours
we are hiring for both our offices in
Palo Alto and San Francisco so come talk
to me afterwards and sorry I had to rush
through the whole thing but if any part
you have any questions how do we manage
the metadata itself
so again early days we started basically
logging them into Hadoop but again we
had the history so we can be processed
those data over
time we started building services
specific for those stuff so we actually
store them in a very organized way but
have the raw data there you can always
use as hard but it's better than it it's
much much better than not having it in
the first place
hey um how did you was a psychology used
to build the modeling tables and all the
derive tables and how difficult was it
to move all of that to become
incremental and to be honest it's it's
hard because it is this you there's no
single solution that addressed all the
modeling needs I am NOT an expert in
that area by the way but in general we
try what we try to do is try to give
them it like a data model that they can
use in different ways and a few
templates that they can they can copy ok
so we have right now again it depends
highly on how you do your modeling if
you have multiple tables joint you
generate something ok you can pull the
changes out of one of them incrementally
ok but if we get the changes from trips
ok that one through from two years ago
is updated that may not necessarily
relate to a user who has updated his his
take out recently so you have to
understand how you use the incremental
processing when you do joints across
different model tables there is a talk
last year we gave in the same conference
we talked about some of the primitives
all of the templates that you can follow
if you're interested you can talk
afterwards or you can watch the same
talk from our semester
you